à quand les deux corées à quand les 2
vietnam c'est la double question que
l'on peut se poser après l'admission
hier à l'onu des deux allemagnes cet
événement a été salué avec chaleur par
tous les membres de l'onu excepté le
représentant de l'état d'israël qui a
déploré l'entrée à l'onu de l'allemagne
de l'est ce pays at il dit n'a pas
acquitté ses dettes de guerre et
soutient les organisations
palestiniennes
toujours est il que l'entrée solennelle
à l'onu des deux allemagne est une
nouvelle date dans l'histoire de
l'europe 28 ans après la fin de la
guerre
cette entrée des deux allemagnes à l'onu
c'est le résultat d'un processus qui a
débuté alors que déferlé sur l'allemagne
à l'est les troupes russes à l'ouest les
troupes américaines après une victoire
totale les vainqueurs se partageront le
pays en zone d'occupation très vite
l'allemagne deviendra la poire de
discorde entre russes et occidentaux
chaque partie marquera sa zone
d'occupation de son empreinte communiste
à l'est libérale et capitaliste à
l'ouest
en 1948 les alliés des 6 2 contre l'avis
des soviétiques de ressusciter un
gouvernement en allemagne occidentale
riposte soviétique le blocus de berlin
qui amène les américains a organisé un
véritable pont aérien de 200 jours pour
sauver la ville de la famine
berlin est devenu l'un des points de
cristallisation de la tension et
l'allemagne l'un des noeuds de la guerre
froide
le 17 juin 1953 les chars russes
interviennent à berlin est il s'agit de
mater une révolte dirigée contre le
régime en vigueur à l'est dans la zone
soviétique pour les allemands de l'ouest
ce jour est devenu jours de deuil
national car il marque le début d'une
séparation toujours plus radicales pour
bloquer l'exode de main d'oeuvre vers
l'ouest qui saigne leurs économies les
dirigeants de l'allemagne de l'est
commencent en outre 63 la construction
du mur de berlin cet acte consacre la
coupure entre deux systèmes économiques
et sociaux inconciliables cette
partition est confirmée plus tard avec
la proclamation de la république
démocratique allemande désormais séparés
par un mur de béton deux états allemands
vent s'il y aurait des parents ou des
amis ne pourront plus se revoir
il faudra attendre l'arrivée au pouvoir
de vie libre aide pour que l'atmosphère
salève profitant de la vague de détente
entre l'est et l'ouest vibrante noura
avec moscou des relations diplomatiques
au prix de la reconnaissance par la
république fédérale des réalités mais
aussi des frontières issues de la
dernière guerre mondiale ce sera la
première étape de l'ostpolitik une
politique d'ouverture à l'est qui en
décembre 72 permettait à bonn et à
berlin est signé un traité fondamental
normalisant les rapports entre les deux
allemagnes dès lors les deux pays
pouvaient être candidats à l'onu mais la
question allemande n'en est pas pour
autant définitivement réglé
la question reste ouverte
même après l'entrée à l'onu de deux
états allemands croient que tout le
monde ça c'est ici dans notre pays
qu'une réunification allemande n'est pas
en vu et que la situation politique en
europe tout va changer profondément
avant que le peuple allemand peut
réclamer son droit à l'autodétermination